herzlich willkommen zu diesem neuen
video wie reagieren wieder auf die
krassesten visual effects diesmal von
avengers wie das ganze davor ausgesehen
hat und was passieren musste uns dazu zu
bringen wie es jetzt in dem film
ausgesehen hatte ich liebe diese
cleveren das wo man einfach nur das 3d
modell noch die schattierung und die
reflexion sieht aber keine farben und
keine texturen bin ich einfach unfall
geil ich weiß nicht wieso ich das so
geil finde aber irgendwie es hat so
einen geilen charme man sieht hier auch
da wo schon fertig ist hat das wirklich
motion blur so bewegungsunschärfe und da
wo es noch nicht fertig ist über diesen
play länder wo man eben das ohne
texturen sieht da hat noch kein motion
blur
das musste natürlich alles danach
hinzufügen damit das möglichst
realistisch aussieht
mit diesem tracking marke auf dem green
screen die hunderte meter lang gehen und
die kamerafahrt nachverfolgen hier weiß
ich auch dass die hier nicht so viele
menschen wirklich verstanden da haben
die die digital nachbearbeitet und
einmal rang kopiert und die für
vielfältig hier wieder ein klärender
leute sagt mir einfach dass es keines
ist so geil aus diese sachen zu sehen
ohne text ruhe weil diese schon so
realistisch aus obwohl noch keine farbe
noch nix da als nur dank dieses gallen
morde links und diesen ganzen details
und das hatten zieht es schon so richtig
viel aus und dass hier was gerade
passiert ist das sogenannte compositing
wenn verschiedene elemente von
filmmaterial und visual effects sachen
zusammen verschmolzen werden mit legt
schattierung noch einer explosion rein
gesetze macht man es nicht alles in
einem arbeitsschritt sondern ganz vielen
arbeitsschritten aber auch ganz ganz
viele menschen arbeiten also einer track
das ganze zum beispiel dann mehrere
leute modellieren an einem objekt sagen
mehrere leute kümmern sich um die
animation des objekts mit leute kümmern
sich um das frost rändern des der der
szene und dann gibt es eben noch mehrere
leute die sich darum kümmern diese
ganzen elemente ebenso zusammenzusetzen
zb mit muss ein rauschen drauf wenn
jetzt was aus dem 3d programm
herausgerechnet werden es dann noch mal
kein rauschen drauf und sieht es noch
mal zu perfekt aus und im echten leben
hat nämlich alles was mit meiner kamera
filmsohn leichten grain zum leichtes
rauschen und da muss natürlich unschärfe
drauf also prinzipiell ist alles was du
in echt films ein bisschen unscharf kam
keiner richtig geilen kamera da kann
natürlich richtig sein aber es trotzdem
bisschen und strafft und nicht so
perfekten 3d programm und dann muss da
chromatischer aberration drauf der
session objektiv fehler wo dann das
licht quasi falsch gebrochen wären dann
zum grünen liga scheint ganz hell
reiche von filmmaterial sind und so was
muss man also mit berücksichtigen und
diesen fehler muss man auf digital
erstellte sachen eben nachhinein noch
einfügen
louis ein feuerwerk und hier wieder
gesagt kleineren da ich es ist so geil
und das hat ja auch richtig geil gemacht
ich liebe es wenn sie sich zum mühe
gegeben weil diesem visual effects
breakdown und nicht einfach nur für
euren nach anzeigen sondern sich auch
noch mühe machen hier die ganzen steine
hier wunderbar sie die alle drauf
rattern dass das richtig macht zusammen
spaß ich kann das wirklich den ganzen
tag anschauen no job auch dass der fluss
okay das ist krass kenne ich mit dem was
er tatsächlich nicht allzu gut aus und
die ganze farben repräsentieren die
strömungen haben sie hier so eine
strömung swap- drüber und die ganzen
partikel die man hier sieht den ganzen
korrekturen hinterher kommen und dieser
clay werden bald wieder okay das ist
wirklich also dieser noch mal ganz kurz
dieser 3d kamera schwenkte jetzt die
kleinste visual effects von respekt
respekt das sind tausende stunden dort
verbracht
diesen bildern wo okay okay okay jetzt
das rosskur punkt da ist das visual
effects jetzt richtig an pumpen werde
mich ein bisschen um diese ganzen
transformer sachen wie jetzt diese ganze
mechaniker so aufklappt richtig geil wie
sie das für dieses special effects
projekte und hier so zeigen diese
explosions darstellung geklappt auch
wieso ein taschenmesser und wieder
zurück und diese ganzen greenscreen
element bluescreen elemente gezeigt
werden nicht schlecht nicht schlecht wie
gesagt ich liebe es auch nicht im detail
die insel effekt braker und reinstecken
und nicht nur nicht nicht mal nur guck
mal du machst du und fehlen der ist
ultra kranke arbeiten 100 hunderttausend
es nicht aber arbeiten tausende leute
dran und dann am ende gehen die noch hin
und geben sich viel mühe für diese
breakdowns um uns zu zeigen wie sie das
gemacht haben einfach nur schön
schön hier ist auch das ist ganz klar
also das ist krass die hatten mit
sicherheit ihre gründe warum die das so
gemacht haben aber hier überrascht mich
das ein bisschen warum die die sache die
leute ja nicht wirklich einfach
gewinnsprung geführt haben sondern die
komplette gemacht haben klar und kam mit
dem mit dem auflösen da ist es hilfreich
wenn man das in der tat mit der
desintegration
also sieht ja so richtig geil aus und
dann zeigen die uns kein fertiges clay
länder sondern einfach nur der vport
play blast von animationen geil da ist
auch der krasse unterschied dass davor
war quasi das womit man dann arbeitet
mit mit dem man die animation macht das
muss natürlich möglichst schnell raus
gerendert werden zieht deswegen auch
nicht so geil aus aber hinterher
man sieht das richtig richtig geil aus
und das ist so der ehrgeiz moment wenn
du stundenlang investiert in die
animation und modeling von irgendeinem
objekt oder von der szene und dann
kannst du zum ersten mal erster ran das
erstellen und zum ersten mal sehen wie
das sind wirklich versehen maximal gut
aussehen kann
und natürlich kommt dann immer noch
mehrere arbeitsschritte aber fraktion
der moment ist man ziemlich geil einfach
einfach geil eigentlich dieses auge aber
auch diese ganzen haare wie diese
details wie die ganzen haare
damit gehen und wie auch diese wie diese
haut da unten als augenlid sich mit welt
wenn diese auch april darüber kommen
auge ist nicht perfekt und das ist so
ein bisschen wie geht sowieso ein
bisschen spitze freunde an der pupille
deswegen wird die haut so ausgedrückt
sehr sehr nettes detail auch darum
wahnsinnig toll ist hier mit seinen
strecken die ich drauf hatte
die nanotechnik okay der police 3
der pulli ist sie die komplette ideal
ich würde einfach mal gerne wissen wie
viele leute da an diese anzeigen sind
hier wieder das was sie gesagt haben
jetzt in newport aus wo man kann sich
einen ganzen animation macht wo es
möglichst schnell laden soll übrigens
viel flüssiges feedback hat und dann
hinterher ins haus gewöhnt
natürlich nach dem kompost alles möglich
ist jetzt richtig gut aus das war es von
heute
wenn ihr jetzt auch inspirierter zeit
kreativ tätig zu werden dann kann ich
euch empfehlen mit dem schneiden
anzufangen wenn ihr schneiden lernen
möchte dann kann ich euch meinen kurs
empfehlen da habe ich verschiedene clips
richtig gut angehört und sortiert damit
er möglichst viel innerhalb von einer
möglichst kurzen zeit lernen könnt check
den trailer in der video beschreibung
aus erfahrt ihr alle informationen ist
natürlich kein abo oder können das ganze
so oft angucken wie er möchte jack das
aus und fans über dem rhein wenn ihr das
video gesehen bin ich gerade in portugal
und liege in der sonne und machen wir
einen schönen und er gibt auch schöne
bilder von portugal sofort nehmen zu
können hier rein und wenn ihr mich auf
dieser reise begleiten möchte dann
abonniere main kanal und dann sehen wir
zunächst mal wieder
[Musik]